they drew how are you today I'm doing
good dance how are you I'm good we were
talking about the first sporting event
we ever went to like that that had some
magnitude you know that that you went to
a professional sporting event do you
remember that first sporting event went
200 let's see here
so I was born in Dallas Dallas Texas
1979 I remember going to IRA my dad
taking me to like an SMU football game
in the early 80s
alright so funny express yeah like that
was that was that was pretty cool right
Craig James Eric Dickerson kind of that
era I I grew up I didn't move to Austin
I lived right next to the University of
Texas Memorial Stadium so I've walked
the games there all the time got to see
some pretty cool games there Colorado
Kordell Stewart and those guys coming to
town in 1994 Notre Dame a couple big
games there
let's see baseball I got to see Nolan
Ryan pitch with the Texas Rangers that
was that was a thrill because he was one
of my my childhood idols yeah but I've
got a lot on the bucket list you know I
still have a lot of sport probably one
of the greatest with my brother and I
were big baseball players growing up for
the College World Series was something
that we always dreamed about right the
old rosenblatt stadium Omaha Nebraska so
I go to college and play football well
my brother walks on at Baylor University
ends up going to the College World
Series in 2005 so I got to go and
basically my childhood dream threw my
brother by watching him play in the
College World Series in 2005 black
that's pretty cool your oldest son his
first sporting event was that the Super
Bowl that you won yeah dad when do I get
my Super Bowl moment a hundred percent
you know because we've got that picture
in his room and he shares a room with
his brothers they don't like to bunk up
together so they see that on the loner
like that was it gonna be my turn we
working on it buddy
just snap your fingers you know and have
that happen and the sun's getting in
trouble you know now they're good boys
this thing that's wrong they love sports
so as long as you just get my ball and
tell them to go in the garage and play
there they're pretty good a lot of a lot
of being a dad's just playing referee
you know just breaking up fights making
sure everything's you know or they're
fighting fair at least so no it's it's a
blast I love being a father less less
having having boys so close an age that
you know we're just you know they're
just best friends how much you keeping
an eye on what's going on with rule
changes the anthem the kickoff you know
there's there's a little bit of drama
here in the offseason yeah
when you say keep up with it you know
I'll hear about it you know and then I
obviously get asked questions about it
I'm the one thorn that's the one that's
interesting I don't I haven't really
looked at closely the kickoff but that
seems to be a pretty significant pretty
significant change at least there's just
a lot of dynamics to it now that you
know are gonna make special teams
coaches you know some strategy yeah I'm
trying to figure it out as well I think
the NFL would like to have the kickoff
removed from the game but it it just
feels like this is gonna bring about
more returns because the receiving team
is gonna have a little more time to come
out of the end zone if they want to
because you're not gonna get that
running start on the kickoff team so it
might it might be counterproductive to
what they're they're trying to do and
that's eliminate all these collisions on
the kickoff that's exactly right I think
that's the end goal right is how do we
continue to make the game safer right
and that's one of the most dangerous
plays in football when you have you know
big strong fast guys running full-speed
and running into each other so how do
you how do you temper that and yet not
take away one of the most exciting plays
in football and potentially one of the
most game-changing type plays you know
with whether it's a kick returner punt
return you know those are those are some
special athletes back there that
everybody likes seeing get a chance to
return a kick so you know I I think some
of the things they do is is an
experiment you know and then hey let's
see how it go
and maybe we find ways to fine-tune it
make it better but at the end of the day
I think the goal is to make it safer
without removing it
I tell the dance if you stand on the
sidelines you don't even have to watch a
kickoff just listen for the collisions
and it's so violent on a kickoff I mean
though you know you're getting ready to
go onto the field so you're probably not
and you've been out there for so many
years to hear it but man the first time
I ever heard a kickoff and just it was
just bodies it was like cars crashing
out there man that's exactly what it is
it's it's a it's about a 40 mile an hour
car crash because you got guys running
about 20 miles an hour going opposite
directions running into each other so
yeah it is extremely violent and I don't
think you get a full appreciation for it
unless you are on the sidelines and you
get to see it at field level hmm you
know kind of in real-time versus being
up in the stands or seen on TV but yeah
it's it's it's definitely violet should
the NFL have worked with the players
Players Association on this new national
anthem rule you know I I don't know I
don't know the extent of who they worked
with or who they didn't work with or or
if it was any type there was any type of
collaboration in regards to it but you
know I think I've made myself very clear
in where I stand in all of this I think
that the national anthem it's a way to
unify everyone I think by some people
kneeling and some people standing and
all that I think that that's very
divisive for our country
and I think that the flag and the
national anthem deserves our respect for
all those who have come before us who
have fought so hard who have died and
sacrificed in order for us to have the
freedoms that we have in this country so
I believe that no matter what you're
protesting because there's plenty of
things about this country that I think
we would all like to see improvements I
just don't think that the National there
the national anthem is a time to voice
those opinions I think that it deserves
our full respect by standing at
attention looking at the flag handed
over your heart singing the national
anthem and paying that respect
I'll make the awkward segue here you're
39 who plays longer you are Brady I
don't know I don't know I'm just taking
one year at a time I'm really enjoying
what I'm doing I love my locker room I
love the guys I love what we're striving
for and so I'm just I'm really just
trying to enjoy the moment stay in the
moment not think I think about the past
not think too far in in the future just
focus on the moment but is this a vote
at home at any point where you just sit
around or you ask your wife or you know
your kids or you know maybe they're too
young to give an honest vote on it on
how long should dad play or is that just
going to be up to you well I will say
this the so it was announced that New
Orleans gets the Super Bowl in 2024 mm
which is which is awesome you know but
here that is six years away so when that
was announced we were all literally
sitting at the dinner table and I said
hey guys what do you think if dad played
in the Super Bowl in New Orleans in 2024
six years from now and we started kind
of going around the table like beylin
how old will you be Bo and how old will
you be and you know they're kind of
counted up and saying how old they're be
they're like yeah dad yeah you have to
play in that one and moms like no no so
listen we're I think if it were up to my
kids dad would play football forever you
know and they get to come in the locker
room and steal the receivers to us out
of the lockers try on Marshawn
Lattimore's helmet and you know jump in
the cold tub hot tub whirlpool and just
hang out with pops in the locker room
but you know come to an end at some
point but I'm just gonna enjoy it while
I care I know that you're joining us
national heat Awareness Day and as you
prep for training camp you wanted to
mention something a product that you're
involved in yeah I tell you what it's
getting hot down here in New Orleans by
the way and it's only May so I hope this
is not sort
chattering for the rest of the summer
and training camp as we'll be down here
but I've had a great relationship with
mission products here since 2014 and
they've developed a great product that's
a cooling towel that not only we use
with the Saints and a lot of teams used
in the league just to stay cool to keep
your core temperature down to help you
perform at a high level but it's
something just for everyday people too I
see the construction workers that are
working on our our building right now
using them guys guys that are out in the
heat all day long just as a way to stay
safe to keep their core temperature down
being that it's national heat Awareness
Day and and obviously we're entering
into the summertime here is something to
be aware of no matter what you do and
mission has a new hydro active max line
for cooling gear that's it's really
revolutionary so again that's mission
towels do you have a website if people
are interested in this is it mission
documen yeah yeah they'd taken part in
making products well great to hear from
you I hope the boys are behaving and
20-24 after the Super Bowl drew will
announce his retirement apparently
that's what we learned from this
conversation drew I can pencil you in
2094 according to my kids yeah that's my
sword I got a couple of sources here
that's all I need I like that mission
calm Thank You drew good to talk to you
I got that's a Drew Brees for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]